the survival genre has pumped out some
incredible experiences since its
Inception no man's Sky rust Minecraft
and more have defined and expanded on
the immersive formula of trying to forge
your way through an unrelenting World
here are some more experiences coming
out in 2023 and beyond that are sure to
scratch that survival itch oh before we
begin I just want to make clear that
these are like the you know scavenge for
resources type of survival crafting
games not survival horror like your
Resident Evils and Silent Hills although
we do love them
Ark survival evolved burst onto the
scene in 2015 with Dinosaur writing and
survival crafting action the combination
of prehistoric and Hyper futuristic Tech
made for an unforgettable experience
that players still enjoy today Studio
wildcard and Grove Street games have
revealed that a sequel is in the works
with the same Dino future aesthetic as
well as Vin Diesel not much is known
about his involvement only that he does
have a family or daughter at the very
least the story that's been teased so
far has you pitted against warring
factions as well as discovering the
futuristic Tech and secrets of the
Future Past on the all-new planet of
Iraq R2 is set to release on Xbox and PC
in 2023
[Music]
the forest made waves when it was
released eight years ago as one of the
best story-based survival experiences
uncovering the mysteries of the island
and its past and present inhabitants is
a thrill and all the more engrossing
when tackled with friends n Knight
Studio continues the same spine chilling
experience with sons of the forest from
the few trailers shown the story follows
your unnamed character after they crash
land on a mysterious island in search of
a missing billionaire who is that
multi-lined woman can I survive the day
without getting eaten by cannibals what
is that horrifying creature Deep dive
into the mysteries of Sons of the forest
when it launches on PC on February 23rd
2023
[Music]
have you ever wondered what would happen
if Pokemon had guns well your dreams
might become a reality if pow World
launches in 2023 palworld is a survival
game set in an open world that lets you
catch and collect creatures called pal
you can make these Newfound friends
build Farm fight and work in factories
to manufacture weapons as you gather
resources the steam page notes that you
can also sell your pal or slaughter them
to eat although this is forbidden by law
survival elements like food shortages
and harsh weather conditions also add to
the survival aspect of your play time
the main Combat Action is focused on
eliminating poacher camps using your pal
to fight with their Elemental type moves
or just with guns palworld is expected
to launch in 2023
the day before is a massive open world
survival MMO set in a zombie apocalypse
fight the undead or other players in
locations that vary from dense urban
areas to rural Landscapes scavenger loot
from locations like malls that feature
stores that mimic real-life vendors like
apple and Louis Vuitton allowing you to
outfit your player in the flashiest gear
the game also includes areas for the
player to take a load off and relax with
other players in saunas and bars the
game looks impressive in size and scale
including cars to navigate the open
World the game is expected to release on
March 1st 2023
Gimli has summoned the dwarves to
reclaim Moria plunge deep into the
procedurally generated minds of Moria
alone or with friends mining is
essential to crafting new and better
gear but beware the more noise you make
the more creatures deep within the mines
will stir and you'll have to take on
some fearsome foes build bases craft
tools and rebuild the ancient mines and
other Dwarven sites as you make your way
through the legendary Misty Mountains
return to Moria releases on PC in 2023
after the Smashing success of shadow of
Chernobyl in 2007 and the two sequels in
2008 and 2009 there hasn't been a
Mainline stalker game in 13 years for
the next installment stalker 2 looks to
bring us back to the Zone created after
a second Chernobyl disaster in 2006 the
Chernobyl exclusion zone is filled with
warring factions and even deadlier
anomalies on top of those challenges
additional survival elements like
Scavenging for rare materials for your
Camp will make sure that your stay in
the zone is not an easy one
it's also important to note that stalker
developer CSG game world was located in
Kiev during the Russian invasion of
Ukraine so development has slowed due to
those external circumstances but stalker
2 is expected to launch sometime in
2023.
the Dune IP is being transported to the
MMO space Dune Awakening hopes to
combine the best of both the survival
and MMO genres to send players out into
the vast Sands of Iraqis you will
inhabit a seamless arrakis with
thousands of other players using third
person crafting in combat to survive you
will come into contact with famous
characters from the books and movies
creating alliances and enemies along
your journey in addition to Base
building and character customization
you'll be able to craft all facets of
Weaponry spice mining mechanisms and
vehicles either combat or Transportation
focused will you rise from the Sands of
arrakis find out by signing up for the
beta now or when Dune Awakening fully
releases on all platforms which is
unannounced
Undead Labs has always brought open
world intricate Co-op survival
experiences to its state of decay games
following the successive State of Decay
2 in 2018 Undead Labs released a teaser
trailer for State of Decay 3 in 2020.
not much is known about the project
other than at least one of the maps will
be set in a vast snow-covered region no
official release date has been given by
Undead Labs or Microsoft but expect the
same Base building zombie infested co-op
gameplay when State of Decay 3 launches
exclusively on PC and Xbox sometime in
the future
fight the FAE in this new fantasy IP
from inflection games travel through a
massive portal Network Solo or with
friends as you unlock the mysteries of
the Realms the Realms boast a wide
variety of biomes and creatures to
interact with along with blueprints and
harvestable resources that you can use
to build tools and weapons that you can
magically enhance alongside the
moment-to-moment Scavenging you can
build your own estate or combine the
state with friends these Estates offer
communities with NPC recruits that can
help you farm expand your home gather
resources and even automate production
times for your little Slice of Heaven
Journey Through the Realms when
Nightingale is expected to launch on PC
in the first half of 2023
enter the Frozen world of frostpunk
bafta nominated Studio 11 bit is
continuing its heralded story of
humanity vs nature frostpunk 2 takes
place 30 years after an apocalyptic
storm has created another Ice Age and
what's left of humanity is now crowded
into massive City centers you are put in
the shoes of a leader of a large city
that is constantly eating through the
little resources it has the gameplay is
city building management and survival
focused as you reach into the Frozen
wastes to gather resources in the first
game Cole was King but now with the move
to oil-based technology will you be able
to keep a hold on the different factions
of your Metropolis how will you lead
with a cold fist or a warm open hand the
choice will be yours when frostpunk
Launches on PC with no proper release
date given
What would life be like on the red
planet occupy Mars is looking to answer
that question with pyramid games new
survival Sim Base building massive
exploration of different areas of the
planet and constant technology
management are some of the different
facets that you will face when building
your new life the game looks to fully
dive into the survival and management
aspects with no form of combat or enemy
Force shown mine for resources craft
different traversal vehicles and brace
for the weather Cycles as you grow your
Colony you can gain Early Access to play
now on Steam but occupy Mars is expected
to launch fully in January of 2023
and there you go from colonies to
distant planets to Pokemon with guns the
survival genre is still bringing a
massive breath of experiences that
anyone can enjoy let me know in the
comments if there are any survival games
that you're super hyped about I'm Stu
and for everything video games keep it
here at GameSpot